hey so guys my name is the channel
welcome back to my Ray tracing series
physically based rendering and materials
we talked about that last time make sure
you check out that video if you haven't
already because today we're going to
extend that and talk about a very very
exciting concept called path tracing so
what is path tracing and why is it
seemingly so hard to Define I mean I did
a lot of Googling before this to try and
get a clear-cut definition of what path
tracing actually is and there are so
many different opinions for what that
term actually means if we just talk
about Ray tracing a lot of people Define
Ray tracing as you have a ray it
originally is usually at the camera it
comes in it hits something and then you
return a color
and that's it some people call that Ray
costing and Ray tracing would mean that
well you don't just stop there you keep
going because if you just cast a ray and
you hit something you return the color
that's Ray casting you've cast your
array you've hit something or you
haven't you return a color tracing okay
so you trace it you kind of keep going
and so that definition would mean okay I
trace my Ray I hit an object and then I
maybe reflect it somewhere and I hit
something else and that's Ray tracing
but in the world of Graphics in general
to say something is Ray traced can
literally mean as simple as I sent array
somewhere to determine some kind of
information so for example Ray Trace
Shadows might mean that okay I've hit a
spot I don't know if I'm in a shadow or
not so I'm gonna Trace array to the
light source meaning I'm literally just
going to draw a line from the surface to
the light source see if there's any
obstruction and that's it Ray Trace
Reflections could mean again I'm gonna
Cast Away from the surface like
reflecting it from The View Vector along
the normal get that reflection Vector
but then actually cast a ray out to see
what I hit and I'm going to take that
into account when I return my final
color right Trace Reflections but then
how do we separate right costing from
Ray tracing my point is it becomes a
little bit muddy when we start talking
about terminology so rather than trying
to give you guys what would be
objectively the correct definition which
I'm not sure really anyone has agreed
upon I want to give you guys the Cherno
definition of all of this stuff so yeah
the way I look at it is Ray casting Ray
tracing they are pretty similar they're
pretty much the same thing maybe I would
consider Ray tracing to be a little bit
deeper meaning that it can bounce around
a little bit but at the end of the day
what I Define Ray tracing to be is I've
cast array somewhere I'm going to hit a
surface I'm going to collect some
information from that hit and I'm going
to keep going probably depending on the
settings of my renderer if I have five
bounces well I'm gonna bounce five times
that's Ray tracing and that's what we're
doing if we look at our application as
it is right now now we're casting Rays
from the camera we're hitting something
we're reflecting them somewhere because
I think we've set it to five bounces
here it is bounces equals five so five
times will hit something will reflect
we'll hit something else we'll reflect
again we'll keep kind of bouncing until
either we hit the sky or we just can't
bounce anymore because we've only
limited it to five bounces that in my
view is Ray tracing what we're doing
here is Ray tracing but there's another
fancy term it's called path tracing so
what is that exactly well if we take a
look at this image again and in fact if
I just kind of freeze it here you can
obviously see that this is extremely
noisy because what's happening is when
our array comes in and hits something
what are we doing at the moment well we
return the color obviously of that
particular pixel right so based on the
material and the lighting conditions
whatever what color that pixel is but
then we bounce somewhere else and where
is it that we bounce well in a random
direction right we come in we hit like
This Is Us coming in we hit this pixel
here and then we might bounce that way
here's the code our right direction is
just our current redirection reflected
along the normal and then based on the
roughness we add some kind of Randomness
to it so in other words if this kind of
blue sphere over here that's our floor
was completely smooth if I just make the
roughness zero you can see we don't
really get that noise anymore because
it's predictable where it will go 100 of
the time but then if I increase the
roughness to like 0.5 or something we
get a lot of noise why because that Ray
is being scattered it's not simply
coming in and being reflected by this
green kind of normal and then going that
way and that's our perfect kind of
deterministic reflection bounce New
Direction whatever you want to call it
every time it's now going in a range and
it could go anywhere here and it will go
a random Direction essentially obviously
within a limit and depending on the
material roughness it will go in an new
random Direction every single time and
that's kind of what causes all of this
noise that's why this isn't smooth it's
because for each pixel it will pick a
completely random Direction but just one
and it will just go in that random
Direction and that will be it then next
frame it will choose a different random
Direction because the direction is
random so every frame is going to be a
new random Direction but if we scale it
back a little bit why are we choosing
random directions I mean again they are
random within a cone essentially within
an area it's not going to go backwards
in this case it's going to be within
some kind of area whose size is going to
be determined by the roughness at the
moment but still like why is it random
does that make sense are we just trying
to randomly generate an image here like
what's going on well we did kind of
touch on this last episode but basically
the thing is if we consider a surface
such as this table lots of light is
hitting it from like every possible
different direction there is some form
of light hitting it I have a huge light
over here and yeah that's hitting it but
then also the wall behind me is
contributing a little bit there's a
window very far off that way that's
contributing a little bit probably so my
point is the whole environment is kind
of just all contributing to the color of
this table and by color I guess what I'm
really talking about is what our eyes
perceive when we look at it now that's
the real world and if you contrast that
to what we're actually doing here with
our algorithm and inside our application
we're doing it in reverse we're going
from the camera we're shooting array so
pretend the camera is my eye I'm
shooting array I'm hitting this table
from my eye and then now I basically
need to evaluate
an infinite number of directions light
hitting this point from an infinite
number of directions which isn't really
possible so what do I do well instead I
basically choose a random Direction now
at the moment because we're kind of
modeling this material that is based off
of roughness we're not really doing
Global illumination and I don't really
want to get into that just here we will
very soon I promise but at the moment we
are just focusing specifically on
reflection but what I'm trying to get
out here is that we clearly need more
than just a single reflection Ray we
need technically like an infinite amount
or near an infinite amount of them but
the current setup of our Ray tracing
application is we hit array we reflect
how many arrays one
we send out one Ray we don't just send
out a billion and remember we're doing
five bounces so what does that mean if I
hit something else now I need to reflect
again in a random Direction potentially
and that's just for reflection
specifically rough reflection reflection
that isn't like a perfect mirror because
that really is kind of one Ray what
about global elimination what about
light just from everywhere hitting these
things these rays are seriously starting
to add up that is where path tracing
comes in because basically what I've
just drawn here hitting this table going
a random Direction hitting that going a
random direction again that is called a
path that is like one path that we
follow and what we need to do is just
evaluate lots of them because think of
it this way if I choose to go in one
random Direction this time why don't I
choose to go a different random
Direction next time and then
average out the result because isn't
that slowly converging on what would be
the result of millions of rays hitting
me and the answer is yes yes you will
begin to converge on realistic lighting
now there's a few things here that
really need some consideration first of
all the way that we're doing it here is
very very Elementary we're just
literally picking a random Direction
like of course we're offsetting the
reflection along the normal so it's not
like completely random but still the way
that we're picking this is kind of
random but I've deliberately set it up
this way because I think it's really
easy to understand and it just makes
everything so much more simple and then
I think in the future it's also going to
be very exciting when we start taking
Concepts that we already know and we
know the whole kind of mechanics of this
and we start introducing real kind of
physically based algorithms and all that
stuff for which by the way we're going
to need a lot of math and uh do you guys
know what a
better get your math yeah I know a guy
brilliant the sponsor of this video I've
talked about brilliant a lot in this
series because they're sponsoring like
the whole series why because this series
ties in really really well with what
they offer and what they can teach you
because what brilliant is is an amazing
website filled with lots and lots of
courses on various stem topics and they
have so many math courses that are
extremely well made they're very Visual
and they're very engaging they'll quiz
you on what they're teaching you to make
sure that you retain the information and
learn and they've got courses about like
everything if this kind of Ray stuff is
confusing you like why what are vectors
why are they reflecting what's the dot
product they have courses that cover all
of that stuff all the way down to this
everyday math course that's perfect for
beginners and their courses are also
super mobile friendly so if you don't
have much time you just want to learn
something on the go it's perfect for
that as well the best thing about
brilliant is that you can get started
for free just go to brilliant.org the
channel check out their courses for
yourself and if you like them and want
to keep going but have been amazing
enough to offer the first 200 of my
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
just check out the link in the
description to get started huge thank
you to brilliant as always for
sponsoring this video so going back to
this little diagram that I drew if we
actually just get out of this and we
watch what's happening here you can see
that the noise pattern so like basically
where like these black areas are it's
different every frame why because we're
evaluating a different path every frame
and if we kind of watch it closely it
almost resembles like what the correct
image looks like so all we really need
to do here is just kind of collect all
of these samples and just accumulate
them into one result and that's what
we're going to take a look at today as
our kind of introduction to path tracing
so what I want to do is inside the
renderer I just want to go back into the
header file and then aside from having
this image data I'm going to duplicate
this and I'm going to make a new array
that's going to be a vek4 and it's going
to be our accumulation
data this you can see I'm throwing in a
floating Point format it's going to be
for floats which is way more data than
this but the benefit here is that
because they are 32 bits per Channel it
can be HDR we can basically hold way
more data than we otherwise would in
here now I'm going to go ahead and jump
into the CBP file and then over here
where we resize that's where we also
need to make sure that we resize our
accumulation data so I'll duplicate
these two lines I'll delete the
accumulation data here and then I'll
allocate this kind of new array of width
times height okay perfect next up we
need to kind of keep track of what frame
of accumulation we're actually on so the
idea is every time we move the camera
it's going to basically reset everything
and then when the camera is still it's
just going to keep collecting samples
keep tracing paths but for that to work
it's important to know what frame we're
on since kind of the beginning of this
accumulation and so what we have to do
is inside the renderer we have to add
the frame index variable which I'm going
to set to 1 by default now y1 why not
zero the reason I'm setting this to one
is because we're actually going to use
this as like the number of paths we've
evaluated in order to then average them
out so in other words we'll have to
divide by this number kind of like
working out an average if you have one
sample you can just divide that sample
by one but if I want the average of two
numbers two and four the average will be
three I do two plus four divided by two
because I have two samples same kind of
story here now I need some kind of API
around this so that externally I can
control it so for example if the camera
moves I need to reset it so let's go
ahead and write a function called reset
frame index and that's simply going to
set frame index to one and then while
we're here I also want to create a
struct here called settings which are
going to be our render settings and
really all I'm going to do here is just
add this accumulate setting here and
basically if that's on we're going to
accumulate samples and if it's off we're
not so if it's off it's going to behave
exactly like it does at the moment that
might be useful sometimes if you don't
want it to accumulate you just want to
fly through your scene for whatever
reason you just wanted to construct the
frame from scratch every frame instead
of accumulate over several frames and
then we need a way to access this and
also actually we need to Store settings
so let's go ahead and install the
settings over here and then I'll also
add a function here to get settings and
that will just return our settings Okay
cool so
what's gonna happen then inside render
this is really where we do all of our
rendering so obviously at the end of
this if our settings accumulate is on
then we're going to do frame index plus
plus otherwise we're just going to set
frame index to one I want to make sure I
reset this just in case we stop
accumulating and then like we're stuck
on frame index 10 for example we need to
go back to one now since we've set up
this API let's go back to our main file
over here Walnut app and then what I'm
going to do is just add some UI around
this so when we have our render button I
want to add another button here called
reset that will just call the reset
function inside our renderer and then
maybe above that I'll just make a
checkbox called accumulate and then that
will be tied to renderer get settings
dot accumulate so we have a way to
disable accumulation and also reset from
within here okay let's actually
implement this accumulation and Trace
some paths so all we really have to do
is if we look at this function this is
what calls per pixel and returns a color
and then what do we do we clamp it to
make sure it's in that range and then we
convert it to rgba and store it inside
our kind of final image data buffer so
what I want to do is when we get the
color the first thing I want to do is
store it as is doesn't matter if it's
not within this range because our
accumulation buffer is capable of
storing floats so it doesn't need to be
clamped to that 0-255 range so let's
paste this in I'll change this to be
accumulation data X Plus y times final
image to get with and instead of just
setting this to color I'm actually going
to add color to it now what's currently
in there well if it's frame index 1
there should be nothing in there because
we're starting again from scratch so
that's the that's kind of step one we
need to make sure that if we're in here
and frame index is one we basically set
this to zero now it's a little bit
annoying to do this this way if you
think about it because that means every
iteration has fallen for every pixel it
manually has to like set it all to zero
and since it's just zero there's a much
easier way to do that what we can do is
actually move this outside of the for
Loop and then I can just mem set the
entire buffer to just be zero so if I
just pass in accumulation data over here
I pass in zero for my value now it does
say int and these are floats but a float
of zero is just all zeros in the memory
there's no difference between the memory
representation of zero for a float or an
INT so that will be fine and then the
size well the size is going to be final
image get width times final image get
height times the size of glm vac 4 which
is going to be 16 bytes so 16 bytes per
pixel so that means that if it is frame
index 1 it will completely reset that
buffer it'll clear that buffer to zero
and then over here when we go through
all of this let me just get rid of this
when we Trace our path and we get our
pixel color we're just going to add it
into that buffer it will be adding into
zero if it's the first time and that's
it otherwise it will add it to whatever
is already in there so the previous
color basically now if we're adding all
of this color together
aren't we just going to get a really
bright image and the answer is yes yes
we will that is why we have to average
out this color or normalize it or
whatever you want to call it before we
actually set it into our final image but
it's totally fine that this is
accumulating that's actually one of the
reasons why we made it a float in the
first place instead of just an INT as in
a float per Channel instead of an INT
per pixel because we want it to be kind
of in a wider range so that it can
actually exceed one so what we can do
here is just pull out that color we can
call this accumulated color or something
like that that will just be whatever
this is so for the first frame it will
be the same as color but otherwise it
will obviously be the full kind of
accumulation of it and then what we want
to do with accumulator color is divide
it by the
frame index so for frame 1 that will be
one obviously and that will mean that we
might as well not do this because we're
just dividing by one but otherwise it's
going to divide by two divide by three
divide by 4 and we are actually going to
get our kind of average color it's going
to give us the kind of combination the
accumulation of all of those samples
that we've done all of those paths that
we've traced and they'll kind of all
contribute to the final result and then
with this accumulated color we can then
clamp it to be between zero and one
after we've done this division because
now it should be in that range unless
we're in an HDR pipeline which we will
explore in the future but since we're
not at the moment and we're just storing
this as one byte per Channel as an
integer we're going to then convert
accumulated color into rgba and store it
back in image data and that's it that's
our full kind of pipeline at the moment
so let's go ahead and
see what this looks like okay cool I
mean that already is accumulating and
looks very cool let's shut off
accumulate and we're going to see how
noisy this looks without accumulation
and then I'm just going to check this
checkbox
and check this out
as I just leave it running it's actually
going to get cleaner and cleaner because
it's going to evaluate more and more
parts okay it's been another like 10
seconds so let's just zoom in a little
bit you can see how much cleaner that
looks I mean that's a pretty decent zoom
level and it just looks very very clean
especially when we're zooming down now
if I play with the roughness here
obviously we're going to have to reset
this when we make any changes because we
haven't hooked it up here but if I just
play with the roughness a little bit so
let's just actually put the roughness to
one and reset it and see what that looks
like because that's a really good kind
of example of just how noisy this can
get like I've turned accumulation off
now and you can see how noisy this is
like there's just so much noise going on
but then I check accumulate
and check this out cleans it right up
and of course we just have much more
information because we're evaluating a
random path every time this is 0.5
roughness
so yeah looking pretty clean and that is
the power of accumulation now if I move
my camera now though you can see that it
almost looks like nothing's happening
and then after a while we might almost
see kind of two images as it begins
combining both of them because of course
I haven't reset it so let's see if we
can do something about that if we go
back to Walnut app you might remember
back from the camera episode that our
camera on update function if we look at
it it actually has this moved Boolean
that we keep track of and every time we
move whether it be like via rotation or
just was ASD QE the keyboard it will set
move to true because we then need to use
that to actually recalculate the view in
the right directions well how about we
just make this update function return a
Boolean and well we can return false if
the right Mouse button isn't pressed
because obviously with our cameras are
in use otherwise we'll just return moved
and then if I go back to the header file
and I will just set on update to return
a Boolean up here as well we now should
be able to to basically just say that if
camera on update returns true that means
that it has been updated some things
changed in the camera which means that
we need to go to the renderer and reset
that frame index so now I should kind of
get that automatically you'll still
probably want to make like all of these
parameters over here in this corner
actually reset that frame index as well
as well as like resizing and all of that
but if I just move this around you can
see that as I'm moving it's all just
incredibly noisy but then as soon as I
stop
it cleans up there you go moving moving
moving noisy noisy noisy then stop and
you can see that it starts accumulating
and we get a much cleaner result over
time this is kind of looking cool as
well this reflection which used to look
like this but then now if we let it
accumulate it looks really smooth and
our frame time is about
130 milliseconds or so on this laptop
which is about 8 frames per second not
very good however now might be a good
time to actually start talking about
multi-threading and optimization and
making this thing a lot faster on the
CPU before we eventually move it to the
GPU now the final thing I want to
mention is that when it comes to
accumulation and how long it takes us to
go from a completely noisy image to
something that's way less noisy but
maybe not perfect and then eventually
when we just like if I left this running
for an hour it would probably look
pretty Flawless however are we really
doing the best job when it comes to
sending out these is Bounce raise and
the answer is absolutely not we're just
sending them out randomly this is where
the quality of your ray is really going
to be important it's almost like quality
over quantity here we can just brute
force it and send out a lot of random
rays and eventually we will convert on a
correct image true however what if we
were a little bit smarter about which
way we chose to send out our array
instead of just being all random about
it because at the end of the day the
quality of your samples the quality of
your bounces the quality of your rays
and parts does play a major role here as
well and there's plenty of things that
we'll explore down that Avenue in the
future such as importance sampling but
that's it while I've been talking this
is cleaned up even more looks absolutely
beautiful hope you guys enjoy this
episode if you did please don't forget
to hit the like button really getting
into some exciting stuff I would love to
know what you guys think we should work
on next should we do some optimization
and actually get this running at like
like 30 frames per second also I'm
pretty sure we could probably achieve
that or should we get into like some
more graphics features such as Shadows
Global elimination we could do some soft
Shadows with area lights that kind of
stuff let me know in the comments
section below also don't forget to check
out brilliant using my link in
description below and I will see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]